Ian: Well Joanna.
Let's write all about Android designs.
Just to summarize, the group view is a fancy word
For a facade --- a vision can lend her children.
Joanna: Exactly, we really have all these interfaces
Let's choose from them, because they are functionally different
In how to place their children.
Ian: Yeah.
For example, linear design is always one row
Or one column, and the frame interface has nested children.
Joanna: Exactly, but if you want to influence
With this overlap or column,
It is necessary to use a layout attribute. "Interface property"
This explains to the system where these children should be.
Let's take such a facade,
Our attractive facade defines the two children,
But in different ways to overlap.
Ian: Uh!
If this is the length and width of the interface
You add them to the children is really
Rules for the father, not for the same scenery.
Joanna: We've made it easy for you
To understand the blog post located in
Description Down where we are
Well we will talk about each interface property you must
Know it, if it is the interface
Suitable for your application already.
Ian: It looks like it'll take time
Joanna: Just a little bit.
Importantly, it is an important resource and you should examine it.
It will help you build better applications.
Ian: I'm the best apps.
I'm the best apps.
Joanna: Stop.
[Music]